training makeup artists prepare to apply
a thick layer of foundation to a pomelo
the round fruit makes a good
approximation for the human skull the
makeup slathered on a bit thick but
they're unlikely to get any complaints
this is a class for volunteer Beauty
morticians who offered to make up the
Dead for free
about getting stuck in a room full of
dead people and there was an old person
who said they can't leave until I put
makeup on all the bodies
some of the skills needed go beyond
those found in an ordinary Beauty Salon
slashes in the pomelo skin approximate
wounds the beauticians might have to
deal with they're taught about skin
tones and little tips to bring back life
to a face for the last time skills that
just need a little fine-tuning
we women are already familiar with
putting makeup on so what could be more
difficult to help make upon dead people
in these tough Economic Times the raw
materials are expensive so the group
relies on donations and today a local
beauty pageant is donating makeup kits
the funeral business was one of the few
to benefit during the covid-19 pandemic
yet prices keep Rising with inflation
funerals are expensive around the world
and Thailand's no exception the main
cost being the casket but the basic
model like this going all the way up to
this which depending on the materials
you choose to use can cost upwards of
thirty five thousand dollars
tavina's latest client arrives from a
local hospital on the outskirts of
Bangkok
she has to work fast the temperature is
nearly 40 degrees
but soon the Ash and skin and sunken
cheeks are transformed
I am thinking how should I make a
deceased look at her best for her family
I usually take around 10 minutes to
finish the job
the eyelashes are the last thing to be
applied secured in place with glue
and then the last fold of the hands and
a moment of reflection
it's an opportunity for her to say
goodbye to a client she never knew but
one who will now depart on her final
Journey with the dignity that would
otherwise have been unaffordable Tony
Chang altazira Bangkok